c'est notre panel politique en compagnie
de stéphanie grammond de la presse puces
et michel serrault j'ai à vous deux
bonne fin d'après midi
stéphanie je commence par vous les
passeports les passeports les passeports
c'est comme si on se demande nettement
incrédule devant l'incapacité du
gouvernement à gérer les passeports et
vous de la vie de ceux qui disent qu'il
aurait dû voir venir les demandes aussi
en nombre
ben absolument parce que c'est clair que
après deux ans de pandémie où les gens
sont restés cloués à la maison et et là
on arrive au premier et et où on sait
que les gens peuvent voyager c'est pas
un mystère les demandes avait baissé
jusqu'à 20% de leur niveau habituel
pendant le début de la pandémie et on
s'imagine émis que ça reviendrait à un
niveau plus normal donc il fallait se
préparer et on le pot fait c'est quand
même fascinant parce que le gouvernement
fédéral est toujours en retard sur la
balle quand il quand les questions de
transport depuis le début de la pandémie
de manière générale on dirait que le
gouvernement a de la difficulté à gérer
la prestation de services à la
population qu'on parle de dépassement en
ce moment où des délais est vraiment
très long par exemple dans le traitement
des dossiers d'immigration et où toutes
sortes d'autres exemples on dirait
qu'ils ont des difficultés à livrer et
puis c'est inadmissible de voir les gens
en ce moment qui attendent est dans
leurs tentes pratiquement et enfile
pendant trente six heures devant la
police qui doit débarquer dans les
bureaux de service canada may fond ce
prêt dans une république de bananes je
me demande compris comment comment tout
ça va finir c'est sûr qu'ils manquent de
personnel partout mais là on a nettement
il faut faire quelque chose c'est qu'ils
les policiers ont été appelés ce s'est
relativement bien passé quand même les
gens restent relativement calme et on
comprend qu'il ya des pleurs ou s'il ya
des la frustration michel est ce que
politiquement il ya un danger pour le
gouvernement
oui bien sûr qu'un danger parce que
s'ils sont capables que faisait
stéphanie de l'hydre et servait sa
population et ce n'est pas le seul
qu'est-ce qui aligne et d'autre part il
faut qu'on dit que beaucoup de gens qui
disent ah les gens qui négligent leurs
passeports échoir excusez moi mais
pendant la pandémie plusieurs bureaux
des passeports étaient fermés service
canada ne côté que les camps essentielle
les bureaux de fass pensons rouvert au
canada tous l'homme depuis le mois
dernier seulement et comme dit à
stéphanie tout chaud et prévisible tout
chaud pour et on pouvait voir venir
d'autant qu'il ya un problème ou au
niveau de la livraison des services
système usant parce que le gouvernement
souvenez vous allez faire une séance du
cabinet complète sur
sur la livraison des services un accès
ce qui est très important c'est ce
qu'ils pouvaient tous les gouvernements
ben c'est pas mal ça démarre et
d'arrivée puis donc stéphanie est ce que
parce que c'est vous le disiez ça
s'ajoute à d'autres choses comme si sur
l'inflation il il bouge pas c'est ils
ont de la difficulté à prendre des
décisions ils sont peu réactif est-ce
que ça fait partie de la personnalité du
gouvernement comment vous vous analyser
ça est-ce qu'il est confortée justin
trudeau par son alliance avec le npd
bizi tout va bien aller pour les trois
prochaines années qu'est ce qui se passe
là bas c'est vrai que ça ressemble un
peu à un sort on dirait que ils sont
déjà partis en vacances puis ils ont pas
eu besoin de passeport mais en même
temps sur le point spécifique de
l'inflation moi personnellement je ne
pense pas que le gouvernement doit elle
doit se met à apprendre toutes sortes de
mesures pour essayer d'aider les ménages
salins peut-être cruel à dire mais dans
un cas comme celui là la meilleure façon
d'agir c'est deriez faire parce que
évidemment les banques centrales sont en
train d'essayer de de resserrer
les taux d'intérêt pour faire en sorte
que combattre l'inflation donc si
gouvernement arrive et jettent de
l'huile sur le feu en donnant encore
plus d'argent pour aider les ménages
mais ça va plutôt nuit donc je sais que
christoph rühl en effet reproché la
semaine dernière d'avoir donné un
discours qui était plutôt tienne mièvre
je sais pas quels qualificatifs utilisés
c'est peut-être vrai mais en même temps
faut se garder dans ce dossier-là
particulier de vouloir en faire trop et
puis de nuire à la place j'avais vu
l'école de ceux qui disent que le
gouvernement doit laisser les choses
aller laisser la banque du canada faire
son travail
oui d'autres pas le problème du discours
de l'onem puis l'a noté tsmc qu'on nous
l'a annoncée comme étant significatif
est pas quelque chose des attentes
étaient plus élevés la plus longue la
women a privé le privé c'est quand le
globe and mail fait sa manchette à
friedel maintenant serait quand même un
peu particulier comme comme situation
mais effectivement si les lorrains
québec a décidé d'envoyer des chèques de
100 donneurs pas promettre si l'élu
c'est peut-être pas effectivement
stephen ireland la chose à faire dans
une période de déflation le travail
c'est vrai c'est la banque du canada qui
peut le faire un grande partie mais il
faut que la banque du canada semble que
le gouvernement acceptera de lui mettre
des bâtons dans les roues de trouver des
solutions politiques qu'un tiers d'impôt
a vendu rennes donc michel fait combien
d'années que vous parlez du rêve bref
depuis le début
encore retardée d'une année bon là ont
une explication c'est qu'il ya un tunnel
qu'il y avait encore des explosifs ça a
retardé donc pour la plupart des
stations ignorant leur retard est-ce que
ça va aboutir un jour le rêve
un jour les jeunes il faut que les élus
l'exclusif date du tabla connaît une
guerre mondiale qui sont dans le tien du
mont royal ça fait presque deux ans
qu'on sait ça alors qu'à un moment donné
ils ont bon dos des explosifs et
d'autre part le problème actuellement
c'est la réputation du constructeur qui
part à cause et le maître le 26 et la
caisse de dépôt et moi je me souviens
quand ça commence et monsieur c'est bien
ce monsieur kalt
m de cpu infra disait ça va être fait
dans l'état et dans les budgets et pour
le rêve de montréal c'est un aspect de
carte de visite pour le montrer dans le
monde entier vous voyez on a fait ça on
a fait autant de temps dans les budgets
dans les temps et le budget est une
série qui s'est installé aux marches
août pour la filiale air froid et
ça va rester ça c'est
tout le drame est basée sur la
réputation de la caisse qui était le
nôtre bodmer dont il aime bien la caisse
a fait des bonnes choses
est ce que ça vient pas démontré
stéphanie que dans les projets de
transport en commun c'est peut-être pas
la place pour des entreprises qui
veulent faire des profits c'est à dire
que c'est le gouvernement qui devrait
faire ce genre de projet stéphane
mais en fait j'ai un peu dans le même
sens que michel et dans la mesure où la
caisse nous avait fait miroiter cette
espèce de miracle le leur de dire nous
on est du privé on va être capable de
faire un projet dans l'étang dans les
délais et puis regardez nous aller là il
y en aura paul ii de mauvaises surprises
et puis ben finalement qu'est ce qu'on
réalise il ya des dépassements de coûts
de plusieurs centaines de millions mais
il ya des retards de plusieurs années et
puis en plus quand on regarde ce 1
visuellement c'est pas très artistique
le résultat qu'on voit si vous allez
faire un tour sur le pot sur le pont
champlain et que vous avez vu les
caténaires elle et les files la hargne
et qui est qui et qui font circuler
l'électricité s'engage
l'esthétique du pont qui est quand même
plutôt joli et évidemment je vous parle
pas là de certains quartiers sont des
figurines parle par le passage d'irene
de l'ouest donc on est loin quand même
de la vision qu'on nous avait présenté
sur plein au tout début donc tout ça
quand même
voix cassée un peu cette idée là du
meilleur qu un entrepreneur du privé lui
va réussir à faire ce que le public
était pas capable et là évidemment on
parle d'europe de l'ouest mais de l'est
aussi michel py vous avez probablement
vu l'entrevue de chantal rouleau la
ministre du gouvernement de la coalition
en irak avec de bois ce matin en disant
ce soit pas un tramway c'est pas un
métro ce sera un très léger et en grande
partie aérien ça me semblait que ça
posait problème le fait que ce soit en
grande partie à
deux jours d'une avec 7 cette entrevue
l'an ou bien madame rouleau ou nous
décrit à la fait à peu près exactement
ce qui était le plat initial donc elle
n'a pas compris ce qui s'est passé à
l'hôtel de ville l'autre jour quand le
premier ministre et la mairesse de
montréal ont dit on enlève le dossier à
la caisse on le donne à la rpm et à la
ville de montréal et si j'allais
travailleront sur le nouveau dossier où
elle n'a pas compris ça où elle elle dit
quelque chose qu'il inverse de son
premier ministre auquel
je sais pas lequel des deux mais quelque
chose qui marche pas il ya plusieurs
choses qui marchent pas avec celle
stéphanie en conclusion rapidement je
dirais j'espère que l'europe de l'est on
va réussir à les concevoir et de concert
avec un plan urbanistique qui fait le
bonheur de l'est parce que ce qu'on voit
dans l'ouest c'est que on éteint avec un
rennes avec un transport structurants
puis on a des stations où les villes se
disant non nous ici on veut pas de
densification comme à pointe claire ou
finalement la population dit ben oui ok
leur haine mais on veut pas avoir d on
veut pas en vendée des constructions
dans notre dans notre cour alors il faut
toujours se fasse sans cohésion et que
saïda part parce que si on pense d
réseau structurant il faut que ça aille
aussi avec un idée de densification
urbaine d'où l'idée d'impliquer plus la
ville dans cette nouvelle mouture du rem
de l'est s'étaient pas ni michel 6 merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé aux panels
bonsoir et merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh